[Music]
welcome to bananamores i'm so excited to
watch this next performer light up
the bananamore stage get ready for
comedy greatness
thank you mitzi i'm percy rostamji and i
want to know how y'all doing
are you guys ready for an indian queer
so look quarantine sucks
okay everything's closed the only thing
opening up slowly are relationships all
right
and if you guys think that you've had a
dry spell
i have been single in celibate for seven
years
you guys like books welcome to
charlotte's web
so i was like i'm going on a date i'm
doing it this is this is my year i'm
gonna do it this will be all said right
this is
i'm going on my first date i'm
vaccinated it's gonna be great so i saw
this guy
at a crosswalk and he looked really cute
and so i walked up on to him
and i noticed he was scary as heck so i
walked on back a little jazz walk i was
like
nope not not not the one uh i mean he
had like you know ripping muscles and
giant biceps and veins popping out of
his eye
okay so i was like don't mess with that
but
on his right bicep in giant tattooed
letters
was the word dancer
i was like oh never judge a book by its
cover unless it's charlotte's web
um i literally turned him by his bicep i
was like you're a dancer
i'm a dancer are you classically trained
i actually toured with janet it was
janet reno but still
uh a little dance of humor which he did
not understand and did not like
uh i looked closer because he was not
reciprocating anything back to me
and his tattoo actually said danger
okay not dancer those are two very
different things
my dangerous dancer so i jazz walked
right out of that situation
and onto a tinder tinder
uh where i met this great guy and he was
lovely and
the conversation was popping and flowing
because that's very important and he was
from the enchanting land of ecuador
this amazing beautiful place uh it's in
south america did not know that
neighbors
uh and he had his beautiful accent but
he's only in town
for one more night so we just had to
meet so our first date was just
me and him and his entire ecuadorian
family
at his godmother's 90th birthday party
dinner on the patio okay safety
and by on the patio i mean the
restaurant threw uh some tarp and some
chairs into the street because that's
what they'd be doing now
they're like it's the safest new way to
eat in the middle of the street
you won't get hit by covered but just by
a bus um and so mid dinner you know
we're enjoying ourselves
uh he's like percy uh i want to
introduce you
it's time atencion atencion this is a
fork
uh mama papa dia prima cabras everybody
come on listen listen
this is my new friend percy and i'm gay
i was mid-wave i was like i got
and i'm gay this is the moment
his entire ecuadorian family looking at
him with adoration and stars in their
eyes my beautiful pure sun
and they pivoted and looked at me like
you did this to our baby
i'm not trying to get beat up i was like
ew your what
that is disgusting what a hard life
grandma
i don't like it we don't like it right
but we don't like it we don't like it
they weren't buying any of that so
that is the story of how i got chased
out of the cheesecake fact
how i jazz rant out of the cheesecake
factory in beverly hills
i'm still single thank you mitzi thank
you everybody i'm percy rastanji
in case you know anybody send them my
way please i'm so lonely
mama i literally did not stop laughing
the whole time
can someone pass me my inhaler